ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב קוונטי שמי John Watrous ואני המנהל הטכני לחינוך ב-IBM
Quantum זה השיעור ה-12 בסדרה והוא השיעור האחרון ביחידה השלישית שעוסקת בניסוח
הכללי של מידע קוונטי השיעור הזה מתמקד במושג יסודי במידע קוונטי שהוא
טיהור של מצב קוונטי טיהור של מצב קוונטי מיוצג על ידי מטריצת צפיפות כלשהי הוא
מצב טהור של מערכת מורכבת גדולה יותר שמשאיר אותנו עם המצב המקורי כשהשאר של המערכת המורכבת
נזרק או מתועקב כל מטריצת צפיפות יש לה טיהור ואפשר ללמוד הרבה
על מצבים קוונטיים ועל מידע קוונטי באופן כללי מלימוד טיהורים ברמה אינטואיטיבית
וקטורי מצב קוונטיים שמייצגים מצבים טהורים הם אובייקטים מתמטיים פשוטים יותר ממטריצות צפיפות ועל ידי חשיבה על
טיהורים של מצבים אנחנו יכולים לראות מצבים קוונטיים שרירותיים של מערכות כחלקים של משהו גדול יותר אבל
פשוט יותר נדבר גם על הנאמנות בין שני מצבים קוונטיים שזה ערך שמכמת את
הדמיון או החפיפה שלהם וזה משמש לעיתים קרובות כדרך למדוד כמה טוב מצב מסוים בהשוואה ל
מצב אידיאלי כלשהו בפרט נדון בהגדרה של נאמנות יחד עם כמה מהתכונות הבסיסיות שלה ונראה
איך נאמנות מתחברת לטיהורים הנה סקירה של השיעור נתחיל עם טיהורים כולל
ההגדרה והוכחה פשוטה לקיום שלהם שמלמדת אותנו איך למצוא אחד אם אנחנו צריכים אחד אז נדון במשהו שנקרא
פירוק Schmidt של וקטור מצב קוונטי של שתי מערכות ונראה איך פירוקי Schmidt קשורים ל
טיהורים אז נדון ביחס חשוב ביותר בין כל שני טיהורים של אותו מצב שנקרא השקילות היוניטרית
של טיהורים ולבסוף נעבור על כמה דוגמאות אז נעבור לנאמנות
כולל ההגדרה שלה וכמה מהתכונות הבסיסיות שלה נדבר על למת המדידה העדינה שזה עובדה
מאוד שימושית שמקשרת נאמנות חזרה למדידות ולבסוף כדי לסיים את השיעור נעבור למשפט Uhlmann שהוא
מבסס קשר יסודי בין נאמנות לטיהורים בואו נתחיל עם
ההגדרה של טיהור טיהור של מצב שנניח שמיוצג על ידי מטריצת
צפיפות הוא מצב טהור של מערכת מורכבת גדולה יותר שמשאיר את המצב המקורי שהתחלנו איתו כשהשאר
של המערכת המורכבת מתועקב אפשר לבטא את זה בצורה מדויקת יותר במונחים מתמטיים כך
אם יש לנו מערכת X שנמצאת במצב כלשהו רו כלומר רו היא מטריצת צפיפות שמייצגת מצב של X
ו-S הוא וקטור מצב קוונטי של זוג מערכות XY כך שתעקוב של Y מהמצב הטהור סי צד ברו פלוס I
משאיר אותנו עם רו אז אנחנו אומרים ש-S הוא טיהור של רו כמובן שהשמות לא משנים אנחנו
יכולים לקרוא למערכות ולמצבים שלנו מה שאנחנו רוצים וגם הסדר של המערכות לא משנה לדוגמה
אם המערכת Y הייתה בצד שמאל ולא בצד ימין אבל כל השאר היה אותו דבר עדיין היינו מתייחסים ל-SAI כטיהור של רו אבל אנחנו
בעיקר נישאר עם ההגדרה הזו לשארית השיעור רק למען הפשטות והדבר הראשון שיש לומר
על ההגדרה הוא שטיהורים תמיד קיימים לכל מטריצת צפיפות רו וליתר דיוק כל מטריצת
צפיפות רו יש טיהור כמו שההגדרה מתארת בתנאי שהמערכת Y לפחות גדולה כמו X כלומר
ש-Y יש לה לפחות כמה מצבים קלאסיים כמו ל-X הרעיון של טיהור ו
העובדה שטיהורים תמיד קיימים מתברר שהיא חשובה מאוד וזה גם חלק ממה שעושה את המידע הקוונטי יפה ובתקווה אני
אצליח לשכנע אתכם בעובדה הזו עד סוף השיעור עכשיו בואו נוכיח שלכל מטריצת צפיפות יש טיהור וב
תהליך נראה איך אפשר להשיג טיהור כשאנחנו צריכים אחד בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו בהגדרה
של טיהור בואו נניח ש-X היא מערכת ורו היא מטריצת צפיפות שמייצגת מצב של
X עכשיו נשקול כל ביטוי של רו כצירוף קמור של מצבים טהורים כמו שכתוב על המסך במילים
עבור בחירה כלשהי של מספר שלם חיובי n יש לנו וקטור הסתברות p 0 עד PN מינוס 1 וכן וקטורי מצב
קוונטיים 5 0 עד 5 מינוס אחד ועל ידי ממוצע של המצבים הטהורים המתאימים משוקללים בהסתברויות אנחנו
מקבלים את רו למשל אפשר להשתמש במשפט הספקטרלי כדי לקבל ביטוי של רו כזה ואם היינו עושים את זה
יכולנו לקחת n כמספר המצבים הקלאסיים של X למעשה יכולנו לקחת n כדרגה של רו שהיא
שווה למספר הערכים העצמיים השונים מאפס של רו כשסופרים כל אחד מספר פעמים שווה לריבוי שלו ו
זה אף פעם לא גדול יותר ממספר המצבים הקלאסיים של X אבל זה יכול להיות קטן יותר מצד שני זה לא
חייב להיות פירוק ספקטרלי של רו ואנחנו לא צריכים שוקטורי המצב הקוונטיים האלה יהיו אורתוגונליים למשל כל ביטוי של רו כזה
מתאים והנה טיהור של רו הסכום רץ על אותם ערכים כמו
בביטוי שלנו של רו ובתוך הסכום אנחנו לוקחים את השורשים הריבועיים של ההסתברויות כפול פי A מטנזור
עם k a פה אגב אנחנו מניחים ש-0 עד n מינוס אחד הם מצבים קלאסיים של המערכת השנייה Y אז
זה הגיוני ש-S הוא וקטור מצב קוונטי של הזוג XY כמו בהגדרה זה לא ממש חשוב
פה שאנחנו משתמשים במצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים של Y בביטוי הזה אפשר להחליף כל אוסף אורתונורמלי של
מצבים במקום K 0 עד Kat n מינוס אחד אם רוצים ועכשיו אפשר לבדוק שזה אכן
טיהור על ידי חישוב העקבה החלקית על Y הנה ביטוי של המצב שמתקבל מביצוע העקבה החלקית
העקבה של k a ברא B היא אחד או אפס תלוי אם a שווה ל-B או לא ולכן הביטוי
מפושט לביטוי המקורי שלנו של רו וזה פשוט ככה אז זה מאוד קל להשיג
טיהור כל עוד יש לנו מספיק מצבים קלאסיים של Y או לחלופין קבוצה אורתונורמלית גדולה מספיק לשימוש ב
מקום מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטיים cat 0 עד cat n מינוס אחד ואגב אם מספר
המצבים הקלאסיים של Y קטן מהדרגה של רו אז לא יהיה טיהור ואני משאיר את זה לכם
להרהר בזה אם תבחרו לעשות זאת הנה דוגמה בואו נשקול
את מטריצת הצפיפות שראינו כמה פעמים בשיעור על מטריצות צפיפות כאן יש לנו ביטוי של מטריצת
הצפיפות הזו כצירוף קמור של מצבים טהורים זה לא פירוק ספקטרלי אבל אנחנו לא
אכפת לנו וכמעט בלי מאמץ בכלל אנחנו יכולים לרשום טיהור של המצב על ידי מעקב אחרי
המתכון זה לא הטיהור היחיד של מטריצת הצפיפות הזו טיהורים הם לא יחידים אבל זה בסדר ה
הגדרה לא אומרת שום דבר על יחידות ולמעשה יש קשר מאוד מעניין בין טיהורים שונים של אותו מצב אבל
נדון בזה קצת אחר כך בשיעור בהמשך נשקול פירוקי Schmidt שהם ביטויים של
וקטורי מצב קוונטיים דו-חלקיים בצורה מסוימת שאני אתאר עוד רגע הם נקראים על שם Erhard
Schmidt אותו Schmidt הידוע מתהליך האורתוגונליזציה של Gram-Schmidt אבל במקרה של פירוקי Schmidt כנראה שלא צריך
לקרוא להם על שם Schmidt זה למעשה שקול מתמטית למשהו שנקרא פירוק ערכים סינגולריים למטריצות שזה משהו שהיה
למעשה התגלה מחדש מספר פעמים אבל זה כן קורה לפעמים אבל בכל מקרה הנה מה שאנחנו מתכוונים
כשאנחנו מתייחסים לפירוק Schmidt עבור בחירה שרירותית של וקטור מצב קוונטי S לזוג
מערכות XY תמיד אפשר לכתוב S בצורה מיוחדת הצורה הזו היא כמו ש
יש לנו פה על המסך כש-R הוא מספר שלם חיובי כלשהו p 0 עד p r מינוס אחד הם מספרים ממשיים חיוביים ש
ביחד יוצרים וקטור הסתברות x0 עד xR מינוס 1 הם וקטורי יחידה שמתאימים למערכת X ו-y0
עד yR מינוס 1 הם וקטורי יחידה שמתאימים למערכת Y עכשיו זה אולי לא נראה במיוחד
מיוחד עד שאני אגיד לכם ששתי הקבוצות x0 עד xR מינוס אחד ו-y0 עד yR מינוס אחד חייבות להיות
אורתונורמליות אז למה זה מיוחד ובכן אם היינו בוחרים בסיס כלשהו לאחת משתי הקבוצות נגיד
וקטורי ה-X שמתאימים למערכת X אז תמיד יכולנו לבטא S בצורה הזו וזה היה מכריח אותנו
לבחור את וקטורי ה-Y בדרך מסוימת למעשה אנחנו עושים את זה באופן שגרתי כמו שאנחנו עושים עם בסיס סטנדרטי כש
אנחנו מכינים את עצמנו לנתח מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי אבל באופן כללי גם אם נבחר בסיס אורתונורמלי לוקטורי
ה-X וקטורי ה-Y שנקבל לא בהכרח יהיו אורתונורמליים באופן דומה אם תבחרו
בסיס אורתונורמלי לוקטורי ה-Y ותנסו לבטא S בצורה שוב תוכלו אבל שוב וקטורי ה-X לא
בהכרח יהיו אורתונורמליים ולבסוף אם כן תבחרו וקטורים אורתונורמליים לשתי המערכות ו
תנסו לבטא S בצורה כזו זה לא בהכרח יעבוד כי אולי תמצאו את עצמכם צריכים איברים מוצלבים אבל יש רק אינדקס
אחד בסכום הזה שהוא a אז הצורה מיוחדת אבל תמיד אפשר
לכתוב וקטור יחידה S נתון בצורה הזו והנה איך אפשר לעשות את זה קודם כל מחשבים פירוק ספקטרלי
למצב המצומצם של אחת משתי המערכות לא משנה איזו אבל כדי לתאר איך זה נעשה בואו נסתכל על המצב המצומצם של
X אז אנחנו מתעקבים על Y זה אומר ש-p 0 עד p r מינוס אחד הם ערכים
עצמיים של המצב המצומצם הזה רו ו-x0 עד xR מינוס אחד הם וקטורים עצמיים יחידתיים שמתאימים לערכים העצמיים האלה ו
אגב ההבנה כאן היא שאנחנו מתעלמים מהאיברים שעבורם הערכים העצמיים הם אפס כי האיברים האלה לא תורמים כלום ל
סכום וזאת אומרת ש-p 0 עד p r מינוס אחד כולם מספרים ממשיים חיוביים ו-R הוא מספר הערכים
העצמיים השונים מאפס כשסופרים ריבויים שהוא שווה לדרגה של רו אז זה נותן לנו את p 0 עד p r
מינוס אחד וכן את x0 עד xR מינוס אחד וכל מה שנשאר הוא למצוא את הוקטורים y0 עד yR מינוס
אחד יש רק בחירה אחת שיכולה לעבוד הוקטורים האלה נקבעים באופן יחיד בשלב הזה והם יכולים
להימצא בקלות באמצעות הנוסחה הפשוטה שמוצגת על המסך ומה שמדהים פה הוא ש
אם נגדיר את הוקטורים האלה בדרך הזו אז מובטח שהם יהיו אורתונורמליים וזה נותן לנו פירוק Schmidt לא אוכיח את זה ב
וידאו הזה אבל זה לא קשה מדי ואפשר לעיין בחומר הכתוב של השיעור אם אתם מעוניינים תבדקו
את תיאור הסרטון ללינק כרגיל כדוגמה בואו נשקול את וקטור
המצב הקוונטי הזה שקיבלנו כטיהור של דוגמת מטריצת הצפיפות שאנחנו חוזרים אליה כל הזמן
זה לא פירוק Schmidt כי מצבי האפס והפלוס הם לא אורתונורמליים אבל אפשר למצוא אחד
באמצעות התהליך שתיארתי זה עתה הצעד הראשון הוא לחשב פירוק ספקטרלי למצב המצומצם
של X שזה אותה דוגמה של מטריצת צפיפות והנה פירוק ספקטרלי שלה שראינו חזרה ב
שיעור 9 אז אנחנו בוחרים p 0 P1 x0 ו-X1 כמו שמוצג
על המסך p 0 ו-P1 הם הערכים העצמיים של רו ו-x0 ו-X1 הם
וקטורים עצמיים יחידתיים מתאימים ולכן נשאר לחשב y0 ו-y1 ואם נעשה את זה נקבל cat Plus
עבור y0 ומינוס 1 כפול Kat minus עבור y1 זה לא מיידי צריך
באמת לעשות את החישוב כדי לראות את זה אבל זה מה שמתקבל וכצפוי שני הוקטורים האלה אורתונורמליים כפי
שהם תמיד יהיו אם עשיתם את החישובים נכון וזה נותן לנו פירוק
Schmidt פירוקי Schmidt הם מאוד שימושיים במצבים רבים ובקרוב נראה מה הם אומרים לנו
על טיהורים טיהורים הם לא יחידים מצב קוונטי נתון שמיוצג
על ידי מטריצת צפיפות יהיו לו למעשה אינסוף טיהורים יש בכל זאת קשר
הדוק שתמיד מתקיים בין כל שני טיהורים של אותו מצב וזה נקרא לפעמים השקילות
היוניטרית של טיהורים הנה איך זה עובד תהי רו מטריצת צפיפות
שמייצגת מצב קוונטי של מערכת X ונניח שיש לנו כל שני טיהורים של המצב הזה שהם
מצבים טהורים של אותה מערכת מורכבת אז למען הקונקרטיות בואו נניח ש-S ו-fi
הם וקטורי מצב קוונטיים של זוג מערכות XY ששניהם נותנים לנו רו כשהמערכת Y מתועקבת
מה שהשקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים אומרת הוא שחייבת להיות פעולה יוניטרית U שפועלת רק על
המערכת Y שממירה SII ל-fi במילים אחרות למרות שאלה
טיהורים שרירותיים של רו ואנחנו לא מניחים עליהם שום דבר חוץ מזה ששניהם מטהרים רו והם
שניהם מצבים של אותה מערכת מורכבת XY הם חייבים להיות שקולים במובן מסוים עד כדי פעולה יוניטרית על Y
בלבד נראה כמה דוגמאות שממחישות למה זה מעניין ומה ההשלכות שלו אבל קודם בואו
נראה למה זה נכון בואו נתחיל עם פירוק ספקטרלי של רו שהיא
מטריצת הצפיפות ששני SII ו-fi מטהרים ובדיוק כמו שעשינו כשדנו בפירוק Schmidt אנחנו
הולכים להניח שזרקנו את כל האיברים שמתאימים לערכים עצמיים אפס אז p 0 עד p r מינוס 1
כולם מספרים ממשיים חיוביים x0 עד xR מינוס אחד הם וקטורים עצמיים אורתונורמליים של רו ו-R הוא ה
דרגה של רו ואגב רק בתור הערה שולית שימו לב כמה פעמים אנחנו נעזרים במשפט הספקטרלי בשלב הזה
זה כלי שימושי להפליא ולמעשה היינו אבודים בלעדיו בכל מקרה עכשיו שיש לנו פירוק
ספקטרלי של רו אפשר לחשב פירוקי Schmidt של שני הוקטורים שלנו בדיוק כמו קודם והם הולכים להיות
כמעט זהים לחלוטין המקדמים ווקטורי ה-X זהים כי הם באים מהפירוק הספקטרלי של המצב המצומצם שהוא
אותו דבר לשני הוקטורים ההבדל היחיד הוא שאנחנו יכולים לקבל וקטורים שונים עבור המערכת השנייה עבור
הוקטור הראשון שהוא S נקבל קבוצה אחת של וקטורים y0 עד yR מינוס אחד ועבור הוקטור השני שהוא f נקבל
אוסף אולי שונה שאפשר לקרוא לו z0 עד zR מינוס אחד אז עכשיו יש לנו פירוקי Schmidt
לשני הוקטורים שלנו שנראים מאוד דומים חוץ מזה שהוקטורים למערכת השנייה עשויים להיות שונים אבל אלה
פירוקי Schmidt אז שני האוספים האלה הם שניהם אורתונורמליים ולכן אפשר פשוט לבחור
מטריצה יוניטרית U ששולחת ya ל-Za לכל a תמיד אפשר לעשות את זה פעולות
יוניטריות הן למעשה שקולות להעתקות לינאריות שממירות בסיס אורתונורמלי אחד לאחר ואם
שתי הקבוצות האלה לא פורשות את כל המרחב שמתאים ל-Y תמיד אפשר להרחיב את שתיהן לבסיסים אורתונורמליים
באמצעות במקרה תהליך האורתוגונליזציה של Gram-Schmidt וככה מוכחת השקילות
היוניטרית של טיהורים בשיעור ארבע של הסדרה דנו בפרוטוקול הקידוד הצפוף
שמאפשר לשולח לשדר שני ביטים קלאסיים למקבל על ידי שליחת qubit אחד במחיר של ebit אחד של
שזירה משותפת אז אני מניח שאתם כבר מכירים את הפרוטוקול הזה והנקודה של הדוגמה הזו היא להסביר בקצרה
איך זה מתחבר לשקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים זכרו שהדרך שהפרוטוקול
עובד היא ש-Alice ו-Bob חולקים ebit או במילים אחרות מצב Bell פי פלוס Alice בוחרת להמיר את
מצב ה-Bell לאחד מארבעת מצבי Bell בהתאם לשני הביטים שהיא רוצה לשלוח ואז היא שולחת את ה-
qubit שלה ל-Bob והוא מודד כדי לראות איזה מצב Bell יש לו שימו לב שכל ארבעת מצבי Bell
נותנים לנו את אותו מצב מצומצם עבור ה-qubit של Bob שהוא המצב המעורב לחלוטין ולמעשה זה כבר מספיק
כדי להסיק שקידוד צפוף אפשרי כל ארבעת מצבי Bell מטהרים את המצב המעורב לחלוטין אז על ידי השקילות
היוניטרית של טיהורים אנחנו יודעים שחייב להיות אפשרי ל-Alice להמיר את מצב Bell פי פלוס ל
כל אחד מהאחרים על ידי הפעלת פעולה יוניטרית כלשהי על ה-qubit שלה כמובן שלא קשה להמציא פעולות יוניטריות ש
באמת עובדות והן מאוד פשוטות אבל זה מעניין בכל זאת שאפשר להגיע למסקנה שזה
אפשרי בלי אפילו לחשוב על הפעולות היוניטריות עצמן ויתרה מזאת אפשר להסיק
שהכללות של קידוד צפוף למערכות גדולות יותר אפשריות בתנאי שיש לנו דרך כלשהי להכליל את מצבי Bell למערכות
גדולות יותר כך שכולם נותנים את המצב המעורב לחלוטין כמצב המצומצם של Bob ויש למעשה דרכים ידועות שונות לעשות
את זה הקשר אחר שבו לשקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים יש השלכות הוא קריפטוגרפיה
קוונטית ואחת מההשלכות החשובות ביותר שלה היא שהיא שוללת את הקיום של פרוטוקול קוונטי מאובטח באופן בלתי מותנה עבור
פרימיטיב קריפטוגרפי שנקרא התחייבות ביט אז מה זה התחייבות ביט התחייבות ביט היא דוגמה
לפרימיטיב קריפטוגרפי שבו הכוונה למשימה או פרוצדורה ברמה נמוכה שמספקת פונקציונליות בסיסית כלשהי ש
אז אפשר להשתמש בה כאבן בניין לעשות דברים מעניינים יותר כמו ליצור סכמות חתימה דיגיטלית או לבנות
פרוטוקולים של ידע אפס למשל במקרה של התחייבות ביט הפונקציונליות הבסיסית היא שאחד
השחקנים Alice יכולה להתחייב לערך בינארי שהיא בוחרת כלפי שחקן שני Bob אבל הבחירה שלה נשארת חבויה
עד שהיא בוחרת לחשוף אותה אנחנו דורשים שני תכונות ספציפיות מפרוטוקול שמיישם התחייבות
ביט הוא חייב להיות מחייב מה שאומר ש-Alice לא יכולה לשנות את דעתה אחרי שהתחייבה לביט והוא
חייב להיות מסתיר מה שאומר ש-Bob לא יכול לקבוע את הביט של Alice עד שהיא בוחרת לחשוף
אותו אז זה היה מאוד נחמד להיות מסוגלים ליישם את הפרימיטיב הזה באמצעות מידע קוונטי כי זה
פרימיטיב שימושי אבל בלי הנחות נוספות מתברר שזה בלתי אפשרי לעשות את זה בצורה מושלמת עם מידע קוונטי או אפילו קרוב
למושלם והשקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים חושפת את זה הרעיון ברמה גבוהה מאוד הוא
שאם היה פרוטוקול קוונטי להתחייבות ביט אז הייתה חייבת להיות גרסה מטוהרת של הפרוטוקול הזה שבו אפשר לדמיין ש
ל-Alice יש מערכת A ל-Bob יש מערכת B ואחרי שההתחייבות נעשית אבל לפני ש-Alice חושפת הזוג AB נמצא ב
אחד משני מצבים טהורים סי אפס או סי אחד תלוי בביט ש-Alice
מתחייבת אליו אם הפרוטוקול מסתיר בצורה מושלמת אז חייב להיות ש-Bob לא יכול להבדיל בין
שתי ההתחייבויות אז המצב המצומצם שלו חייב להיות אותו דבר לשתי האפשרויות אבל זה מרמז על ידי
השקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים ש-Alice יכולה להמיר כל אחד מהם לאחר על ידי הפעלת פעולה
יוניטרית כלשהי על A בלבד אז הפרוטוקול נכשל לחלוטין מלהיות מחייב יש שם פרטים ש
טאטאתי מתחת לשטיח אבל לב העניין הוא שהשקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים אומרת לנו שהפרימיטיב הזה הוא לא משהו
שאנחנו יכולים ליישם בצורה אמינה באמצעות מידע קוונטי בלי הנחות נוספות מסוג
כלשהו הדוגמה האחרונה של השלכה של השקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים היא משפט שנקרא
משפט Hughston-Jozsa-Wootters או משפט HJW בקיצור בואו נתחיל עם ניסוח
המשפט עצמו וזו גרסה מעט מפושטת שלו רק כדי להימנע מכמה טכניקליות כך שנוכל להתמקד ברעיונות
המרכזיים נניח ש-X ו-Y הם מערכות ו-F הוא וקטור מצב קוונטי כלשהו שמייצג מצב טהור של הזוג
XY ועכשיו נניח שאנחנו חושבים על המצב המצומצם של המערכת X לבדה ומוצאים דרך כלשהי ש
אנחנו בוחרים לבטא את המצב המצומצם הזה כצירוף קמור של מצבים טהורים כמו שמוצג על המסך
אז למשל המספר N גדול בביטוי הזה שהוא מספר המצבים הטהורים שאנחנו ממצעים עליהם יכול
להיות גדול שרירותית אולי הרבה יותר גדול מהמימד של המרחב שמתאים ל-X או ל-Y לצורך
העניין ומה שהמשפט אומר לנו הוא שחייבת להתקיים מדידה על המערכת Y עם n תוצאות כך ש
הדבר הבא קורה כשהמערכת Y נמדדת קודם כל כל תוצאת מדידה
מופיעה בהסתברות שווה בדיוק להסתברות המתאימה בביטוי שלנו של המצב המצומצם של X כ
צירוף קמור של מצבים טהורים ושנית בהתניה על קבלת תוצאת מדידה מסוימת
המצב של X הופך למצב הטהור המתאים מהצירוף הקמור אז למה זה
מעניין ובכן זה אומר שלכל דרך שנבחר לחשוב על המצב המצומצם של X כצירוף
קמור של מצבים טהורים יש מדידה כלשהי של Y שלמעשה הופכת את הדרך הזו לחשוב על המצב המצומצם של X ל
מציאות ומה שמרשים הוא שזה אפשרי גם כשהמצב F נבחר קודם והצירוף
הקמור נבחר אחר כך כל עוד זה ביטוי של המצב המצומצם של X תהיה
מדידה של Y שעובדת בדיוק ככה אז בואו נראה איך אפשר להוכיח
את זה אנחנו מתחילים עם שני ביטויים שונים למצב המצומצם של X שנקרא לו רו ל
נוחות בהמשך אנחנו מציגים מערכת חדשה Z שהמצבים הקלאסיים שלה הם תוצאות המדידה האפשריות או
באופן שקול האינדקסים בצירוף הקמור שלנו ועכשיו אפשר לראות ששני וקטורי המצב הקוונטיים הבאים
גמא 0 וגמא 1 ששניהם וקטורי מצב של המערכת המורכבת XYZ הם
שניהם טיהורים של רו ורק כדי להבהיר כשאנחנו חושבים על הוקטורים האלה כטיהורים של רו אנחנו
חושבים על המערכות Y ו-Z ביחד כמערכת מורכבת אחת שמתועקבת כדי להשאיר
את רו הוקטור הראשון גמא 0 הוא בעצם אותו דבר כמו המצב הטהור המקורי פי חוץ מזה שאנחנו
מאתחלים את המערכת החדשה Z למצב אפס ברור שאם נתעקב על Y ו-Z נישאר עם רו אז גמא
0 הוא טיהור של רו הוקטור השני גמא 1 הוא בעצם הוקטור שמתקבל מטיהור
רו על בסיס הצירוף הקמור בדיוק כמו שתיארתי קודם בשיעור הפעם המערכת Y
מאותחלת ואני מניח רק למען הפשטות שאפס הוא מצב קלאסי של Y אבל אפשר להחליף כל
מצב בסיס סטנדרטי או למעשה כל מצב טהור של Y לתוך הביטוי הזה וזה לא ישנה כלום בכל מקרה תעקוב על Y ו
Z שוב משאיר אותנו עם רו אז השורה התחתונה היא ששניהם טיהורים של רו ולכן על ידי
השקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים יש פעולה יוניטרית U על הזוג YZ שממירה גמא 0 ל
גמא 1 וזה כל מה שאנחנו צריכים כדי למצוא תיאור של מדידה שעושה את מה שהמשפט
אומר דרך פשוטה לתאר את זה היא עם דיאגרמת circuit כמו שמוצג פה על המסך במילים אנחנו מתחילים עם
המצב F מציגים Z מאותחל למצב אפס מבצעים U ואז מודדים את המערכת העליונה שהיא Z עם
מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי למעשה מה שזה עושה הוא להמיר fi לגמא אחד ו
רק מלהסתכל על התיאור של גמא 1 אפשר לראות שזה עושה את מה שהמשפט אומר כלומר שאנחנו מקבלים
כל תוצאה a בהסתברות PA ובהתניה על קבלת a המערכת X נשארת במצב sa
a ורק כדי להבהיר המדידה עצמה שהמשפט מרמז על קיומה מיושמת על ידי
כל מה שבמלבן המקווקו באיור ואם אתם רוצים לדעת איך ה
מדידה יכולה להיות מתוארת כאוסף של מטריצות הנה ביטוי שלהן לא אסביר את החלק הזה וזה
לא ממש חשוב למען הדוגמה אבל זה ביטוי של מטריצות המדידה למקרה שאתם
מעוניינים בהמשך נדון בנאמנות שהיא מדד לכמה דומים שני מצבים קוונטיים או לחלופין כמה
הם חופפים נתחיל עם ההגדרה שאולי נראית קצת מסתורית ב
מבט ראשון אבל נפרק אותה ובסוף הדיון אני מקווה שאשכנע אתכם שזו
למעשה פונקציה הרבה יותר נחמדה ממה שהיא נראית במבט ראשון והנה
ההגדרה הנאמנות בין שתי מטריצות צפיפות רו וסיגמא שווה לעקבה של השורש הריבועי של
השורש הריבועי של רו כפול סיגמא כפול השורש הריבועי של רו נדבר על
זה קודם בואו ננסה להבין את ההגדרה עצמה יש לנו שלושה שורשים ריבועיים ו
כולם מתייחסים לשורש ריבועי של מטריצה חיובית חצי-מוגדרת שכפי שדנו בשיעור הקודם היא
המטריצה החיובית חצי-מוגדרת היחידה שבריבוע נותנת לנו את המטריצה שאנחנו לוקחים לה שורש כי
רו היא מטריצת צפיפות היא חייבת להיות חיובית חצי-מוגדרת אז אפשר לקחת לה שורש ואם נחשוב על שורש רו כפול
סיגמא כפול שורש רו לרגע נראה שזה גם חיובי חצי-מוגדר ובפרט אפשר לכתוב את זה כ
M כוכבית כפול M כש-M הוא שורש סיגמא כפול שורש רו ולכן אפשר לקחת את השורש
הריבועי שלו בפרט אפשר לחשב פירוק ספקטרלי של שורש
רו כפול סיגמא כפול שורש רו ואז כדי לקחת את השורש אנחנו רק צריכים לקחת את השורשים של הערכים
העצמיים ולהשאיר את הוקטורים העצמיים כמו שהם ולבסוף אנחנו לוקחים את העקבה של
המטריצה הזו וכיוון שהעקבה שווה לסכום הערכים העצמיים אנחנו מקבלים את הביטוי שיש לנו ממש
כאן אז זה כנראה משהו שלא תרצו לחשב ביד באופן כללי וההסבר הזה אולי לא
מציע הרבה תובנה לגבי הנאמנות או למה אכפת לנו ממנה אבל בתקווה זה מבהיר את המשמעות הטכנית
של הנוסחה אגב רק בתור הערה שולית לפעמים אנשים מגדירים את הנאמנות
כריבוע של הפונקציה שהגדרתי כאן ומתייחסים לפונקציה הזו כשורש
הנאמנות תראו את זה מוגדר בשתי הדרכים מה שבהחלט יכול לגרום לבלבול אבל בדרך כלל זה לא קורה
כי אנשים בדרך כלל מקפידים להבהיר באיזו הגדרה הם משתמשים ואתם צריכים
לדאוג לעשות את אותו הדבר לעיניי באמת אין הגדרה נכונה או לא נכונה אני מגדיר את זה
ככה פשוט כי התרגלתי לעשות את זה ככה ואני כן מוצא שזה קצת יותר נוח אני מניח כי אני מעדיף לעלות בריבוע
משהו מאשר לקחת שורש ריבועי מאוחר יותר כשעולה הצורך אבל כמובן אתם חופשיים לעשות את הבחירה
שלכם אבל בכל מקרה תנו לי לחזור לנאמנות כפי שהיא מוגדרת כאן יש דרכים שקולות אחרות
להגדיר את הנאמנות וזו למעשה פונקציה די מרשימה בהיבט הזה ואפשר למעשה לאפיין אותה בכמה דרכים מעניינות
למדי הנה דרך די ישירה לכתוב מחדש את ההגדרה במונחים של נורמת העקבה שראינו לקראת
סוף השיעור הקודם לא נכנסתי ליותר מדי פרטים על נורמת העקבה ובפרט אני
אפילו לא הגדרתי אותה למטריצות לא הרמיטיות אבל יש לה הגדרה פשוטה מספיק דרך אחת להגדיר את נורמת העקבה של
מטריצה שרירותית M היא שזו העקבה של השורש הריבועי של M כפול M דאגר או באופן שקול העקבה של השורש
הריבועי של M דאגר כפול M מקבלים את אותו ערך בכל מקרה ואפשר להשתמש בהגדרה הזו כדי לפשט את
ההגדרה של הנאמנות כמו שיש לנו למטה על המסך וזה נחמד כי זה חושף ש
זה סימטרי בשני הארגומנטים אפשר גם לבטא את נורמת העקבה של מטריצה ריבועית M כ
מקסימום של הערך המוחלט של העקבה של M כפול U על פני כל המטריצות היוניטריות U מה שלא מובן מאליו אבל
כן נכון וזה נותן לנו ביטוי נוסף לנאמנות אז יש לנו כאן שלוש
הגדרות שקולות לנאמנות וזו רק ההתחלה יש עוד כמה הגדרות שקולות ו
נראה אחת חשובה במיוחד שבאה ממשפט Uhlmann לקראת סוף השיעור
אוקיי אז זה בסדר אבל מה כל זה אומר ברמה אינטואיטיבית ולמה צריך לאכפת לנו מהפונקציה
הזו כדי לענות על השאלות האלה זה עוזר לשקול את המקרה המיוחד שבו לפחות אחת משתי מטריצות
הצפיפות מייצגת מצב טהור אם שני המצבים טהורים אז ה
נאמנות היא פשוט הערך המוחלט של המכפלה הפנימית בין שני וקטורי המצב הקוונטיים ובמובנים מסוימים
זו המוטיבציה העיקרית לנאמנות עצמה הערך המוחלט של המכפלה הפנימית בין שני וקטורי מצב
קוונטיים הוא תמיד מספר בין אפס לאחד וזה נותן לנו דרך טבעית למדוד כמה חפיפה יש
בין שני וקטורי מצב קוונטיים ואפשר לחשוב על הנאמנות כדרך שימושית ומתנהגת היטב
להרחיב את הדרך הזו למדוד חפיפה ממצבים טהורים למטריצות צפיפות אם אחד מהמצבים טהור
והשני לא בהכרח טהור אז שוב יש לנו ביטוי פשוט לנאמנות שיכול להיות מאוד
שימושי והביטוי הזה מוצג ממש כאן לנאמנות יש הרבה תכונות מעניינות
וזו אחת הסיבות שאנשים משתמשים בה יש לה הגדרה שלא ממש
נחמדה אבל זו פונקציה מאוד שימושית בכל זאת ולעיתים קרובות מאוד קל להשתמש בה בין השאר בגלל התכונות המדהימות הרבות שלה
אז בואו נסתכל על כמה מהן נתחיל עם התצפית שהנאמנות בין שתי מטריצות
צפיפות היא תמיד מספר בין 0 לאחד היא אפס אם ורק אם המצבים
אורתוגונליים כלומר שהתמונות הן תת-מרחבים אורתוגונליים או באופן שקול שהמכפלה של שתי המטריצות היא
אפס והנאמנות היא אחד אם ורק אם שתי מטריצות הצפיפות שוות כל מקרה אחר הוא איפשהו ב
אמצע אבל באופן אינטואיטיבי ככל שהנאמנות קרובה יותר לאחד ככה המצבים דומים יותר או לחלופין
ככה הם חופפים יותר הנאמנות היא גם סימטרית הזכרתי את זה לפני כמה רגעים זה
די ברור מהביטוי שראינו לנאמנות במונחים של נורמת העקבה אבל זה דבר חשוב להכיר
בכל זאת בהמשך הנאמנות היא כפלית למצבי מכפלה כלומר הנאמנות בין שני
מצבי מכפלה תמיד שווה למכפלת הנאמנויות בין המצבים הבודדים
הנה תכונה ממש שימושית אם יש לנו שתי מטריצות צפיפות באותו גודל
יחד עם ערוץ כלשהו שלוקח את מטריצות הצפיפות האלה כקלט הנאמנות יכולה רק לגדול כשהערוץ
מופעל על שני המצבים אז במילים אחרות מבחינת הנאמנות ערוצים יכולים רק להפוך מצבים
לדומים יותר זה לזה הם לא יכולים להפוך אותם לפחות דומים ולבסוף ברשימה הזו בכל מקרה
יש קשר די הדוק בין הנאמנות למרחק העקבה בין מצבים שמוגדר
כחצי מנורמת העקבה של ההפרש בין שתי מטריצות הצפיפות מרחק העקבה בין שני
מצבים קשור חזק ליכולת שלנו להבחין ביניהם מה שדנו בו בשיעור הקודם בהקשר של
הבחנת מצבים ומשפט Helstrom-Holevo בעוד שהנאמנות מכמתת כמה שני מצבים
חופפים אז למרות שזה לא בדיוק אותו דבר זה לא מפתיע שיש קשר בין
שני הגדלים האלה אבל בכל מקרה האי-שוויונות האלה שנקראות בדרך כלל אי-שוויונות Fuchs-van de Graaf הופכות
את הקשר הזה למדויק מתמטית וזה מאוד חשוב שאין פה בכלל תלות בגודל המערכת שאנחנו מדברים
עליה אפשר לראות את הקשר הזה בצורה ברורה יותר בעזרת איור אם יש לנו שני מצבים ו
נמקם את מרחק העקבה ביניהם על ציר ה-X והנאמנות על ציר ה-Y אז הקווים האנכיים
והאופקיים המתאימים חייבים להיחתך איפשהו בתוך האזור האפור הזה האזור המעניין ביותר של
התרשים אגב לפחות מבחינה מעשית הוא הפינה השמאלית העליונה של האזור האפור בפרט כש
מרחק העקבה מאוד קטן הנאמנות חייבת להיות מאוד קרובה לאחד ולהפך
האי-שוויונות האלה משמשות מאוד לעיתים קרובות וחלק מהסיבה לכך הוא שלעיתים קרובות אכפת לנו יותר מ
מרחק העקבה בסופו של דבר כי יש לו פרשנות טבעית שמתחברת להבחנת מצבים קוונטיים
אבל לנאמנות יש כל כך הרבה תכונות מדהימות שבדרך כלל קל יותר לעבוד איתה וכל עוד אנחנו בפינה השמאלית העליונה של
האזור האפור שזה לעיתים קרובות איפה שאנחנו נמצאים אנחנו לא מפסידים הרבה מהמרה הלוך וחזור בין הנאמנות למרחק העקבה אז אלה
כמה מהתכונות של הנאמנות יש עוד הרבה אבל זו התחלה טובה ובתקווה הרשימה
עוזרת להתחיל לפתח אינטואיציה לגבי הנאמנות הנה דוגמה נחמדה לאיך אפשר
לקשר את הנאמנות למדידות לא הרסניות זו עובדה מאוד שימושית שנקראת למת המדידה
העדינה נניח שיש לנו מערכת X מצב של X שמיוצג על ידי מטריצת צפיפות רו ומדידה על מערכת X
שמתוארת על ידי אוסף של מטריצות חיוביות חצי-מוגדרות נניח שאחת מתוצאות המדידה מאוד סבירה
להופיע אם היינו מבצעים את המדידה על המצב רו רק למען הפשטות נניח
שזו התוצאה אפס אפס שמאוד סבירה ובפרט נניח שהתוצאה הזו מופיעה בהסתברות
גדולה מ-1 מינוס אפסילון עבור ערך קטן כלשהו של אפסילון שאנחנו לא ממש צריכים לציין אפסילון
הוא סתם מספר ממשי חיובי קטן כלשהו עכשיו תיארנו את המדידה שלנו כאילו היא מדידה
הרסנית אבל אנחנו כן יודעים מהשיעור הקודם שאפשר ליישם את המדידה הזו בצורה לא הרסנית ובפרט אפשר לעשות את זה כמו
שראינו בדיון שלנו על משפט Naimark וזה עובד ככה כל תוצאה a מופיעה ב
הסתברות שווה לעקבה של PA כפול רו ובהתניה על קבלת התוצאה הזו המצב של X משתנה ב
פרט במקרה שאנחנו מקבלים את התוצאה הסבירה אפס המצב הופך לשורש של p 0 כפול רו כפול שורש של p 0
הכל מנורמל כך שנקבל מטריצת צפיפות ומה שלמת המדידה העדינה אומרת לנו הוא שבמקרה הזה
כלומר שאנחנו אכן מקבלים את תוצאת המדידה הסבירה המצב שנקבל לא ישתנה הרבה מ
המצב המקורי ובפרט הנאמנות בריבוע בהכרח תהיה גדולה מ-1 מינוס
אפסילון וזה מעולה כי זה לגמרי כללי לא אמרנו שום דבר על המדידה או
המצב חוץ מזה שאחת מהתוצאות מאוד סבירה אז אפשר להפעיל את הלמה ב
הרבה הקשרים שונים שבהם היינו רוצים לאמת משהו על מצב קוונטי בלי להפריע לו יותר מדי אז בואו נראה איך אפשר להוכיח
את זה וברובו זה למעשה עניין די פשוט של חישוב הנאמנות בין המצב לפני ואחרי המדידה
אפשר לעשות את זה באמצעות ההגדרה המקורית ובדרך כלל זה היה משאיר אותנו עם נוסחה מבולגנת אבל
במקרה הזה יש לנו מזל כי הדבר שבתוך השורש הריבועי החיצוני הוא למעשה ריבוע של מטריצה ש
במקרה היא חיובית חצי-מוגדרת מה שהופך את חישוב השורש לטריוויאלי עכשיו אפשר להשתמש בתכונה
המחזורית של העקבה יחד עם הליניאריות של העקבה כדי לפשט את הביטוי שלנו כמו שמוצג על המסך שימו לב אגב שאלה
כולם שוויונות אז לא קירבנו שום דבר בשלב הזה אנחנו באמת רק מפשטים אבל עכשיו אנחנו כן צריכים
אי-שוויון כי היינו רוצים להיפטר מהשורש הריבועי במונה ואנחנו אכן יכולים לעשות את זה אם אנחנו מוכנים להסתפק בחסם תחתון ואם
אתם מעוניינים בפרטים של החלק הזה אפשר לקבל את אי-השוויון די בקלות על ידי שקילת פירוק ספקטרלי של p
0 הערכים העצמיים של p 0 חייבים להיות בין 0 לאחד זה תמיד נכון עבור מטריצות שמתארות
מדידות וברגע שאנחנו יודעים את זה אי-השוויון נובע די ישירות מהעובדה שלקיחת שורש ריבועי של
מספר בין 0 לאחד יכולה רק להגדיל אותו דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שהעלאה בריבוע של מספר בין אפס ל
אחד יכולה רק להקטין אותו עכשיו אפשר לפשט עוד קצת ונקבל את
השורש הריבועי של העקבה של p 0 כפול רו לבסוף מעלים בריבוע את שני הצדדים ו
מציבים את החסם שלנו על ההסתברות נותן לנו את מה שרצינו אז הנוסחה לנאמנות
היא לא הנוסחה הכי נחמדה או הכי קלה לשימוש בעולם אבל כאן היא למעשה עובדת די
יפה כדי לסיים את השיעור נסתכל על משפט Uhlmann שהוא עובדה יסודית על הנאמנות ש
מקשרת אותה לרעיון של טיהור מה שהמשפט אומר במילים פשוטות הוא שהנאמנות בין כל שני
מצבים קוונטיים שווה למכפלה הפנימית המקסימלית בערך מוחלט בין שני טיהורים של אותם
מצבים ביתר פירוט נניח שרו וסיגמא הם מטריצות צפיפות למערכת X כלשהי ונניח ש-Y היא
מערכת שיש לה לפחות כמה מצבים קלאסיים כמו ל-X ולכן מובטח ששני המצבים האלה יש להם טיהורים שהם
וקטורי מצב קוונטיים של XY אפשר אז לבטא את המשמעות של המשפט בצורת המשוואה
שמוצגת על המסך הנאמנות בין רו וסיגמא שווה למקסימום של הערך המוחלט של המכפלה הפנימית
בין F ו-SII על פני כל F ו-S שמטהרים רו וסיגמא
בהתאמה אז בואו ננקה את זה ונעבוד עם הניסוח המתמטי המדויק מעכשיו מה שנעשה עכשיו הוא להוכיח
את המשפט אבל קודם שווה לעצור רגע ולהעריך שהוא מציע לנו דרך די אינטואיטיבית לחשוב על
הנאמנות הוא גם במקרה מאוד שימושי בפני עצמו למשל כדי להוכיח דברים עוד יותר מעניינים על
הנאמנות כדי להוכיח אותו נתחיל עם פירוקים ספקטרליים של מטריצות
הצפיפות שלנו אין הפתעות פה ברגע שיש לנו פירוקים ספקטרליים קל להמציא
שני טיהורים ספציפיים של המצבים האלה אבל פה אנחנו למעשה הולכים לעשות
טריק שימו לב שבשני המקרים אין לנו וקטור בסיס סטנדרטי בתור גורם הטנזור השני כמו שהיה לנו קודם ב
שיעור אלא יש לנו את אותו וקטור כמו בגורם הטנזור הראשון רק שיש עליו קו ו
זה אומר הצמוד המרוכב איבר-איבר של הוקטורים האלה אז במילים אחרות אנחנו בעצם רק לוקחים
עותק שני של הוקטורים העצמיים אבל לוקחים את הצמוד המרוכב של כל כניסה ונראה למה אנחנו עושים את זה בעוד כמה
רגעים אבל זה בכלל לא מובן מאליו שצריך לעשות את זה ולכן אנחנו קוראים לזה
טריק בכל מקרה אלה טיהורים של רו וסיגמא בהתאמה וזה נכון מכוח
העובדה שהוקטורים העצמיים שלנו אורתונורמליים ולכן גם הצמודים המרוכבים איבר-איבר שלהם ועכשיו אפשר להפעיל את
השקילות היוניטרית של טיהורים שאומרת שכל טיהור של שני המצבים שלנו אפשר לקבל על ידי
הפעלת פעולה יוניטרית על המערכת שמתועקבת עבור הבחירות הספציפיות של טיהורים ש
זה עתה עשינו הפעולות היוניטריות לא חייבות להיות אותו דבר לשני הטיהורים
כמובן אז פה אנחנו משתמשים באות U לראשון ובאות V לשני
אז הנקודה היא שכל טיהור של שני המצבים שלנו אפשר לכתוב כמו שיש לנו על המסך עבור
בחירה כלשהי של פעולות יוניטריות U ו-V ועכשיו אפשר לקחת את הביטוי
מהמשפט ולפשט אם נציב את הביטויים שלנו ל-F ו-S ונפשט קצת
נקבל את הביטוי שמוצג כאן על המסך עכשיו יש שם כמה צעדים ולא הראיתי את הפרטים
אז אתם יודעים מה לעשות אם אתם רוצים לעשות את זה אבל תנו לי להזכיר שהסיבה שבחרנו את הטיהורים כמו שבחרנו
הייתה כדי לאפשר למכפלה הפנימית הזו להתפשט בדיוק בצורה הזו ובפרט שמנו שם את הצמודים המרוכבים
כדי שנוכל למעשה להפוך את המכפלות הפנימיות בגורם הטנזור השני כדי לקבל את הצורה הספציפית
שיש לנו ממש כאן אנחנו כמעט שם עכשיו אפשר להשתמש בתכונה המחזורית של העקבה ביחד
עם הפירוקים הספקטרליים שהתחלנו איתם כדי לקבל את הביטוי הזה ובשלב הזה אפשר
להשתמש באחת מהדרכים החלופיות לביטוי הנאמנות באמצעות נורמת העקבה ו
סיימנו בהחלט יש שם פרטים שדילגתי עליהם מהר מאוד וזה סוג ההוכחה ש
באמת צריך לעבור עליה בעצמכם כדי להבין לגמרי אבל בתקווה זה נותן לכם את הרעיון
הבסיסי וכרגיל אפשר למצוא פרטים נוספים בתוכן הכתוב של השיעור שמקושר בתיאור הסרטון
וזה סוף השיעור שעסק בטיהורים נאמנות והקשרים ביניהם וזה גם
סוף היחידה שעסקה בניסוח הכללי של מידע קוונטי אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי ל
יחידה הרביעית והאחרונה של הסדרה שעוסקת בתיקון שגיאות קוונטי תודה שצפיתם